[Music]
the mvp is happy even though he's not
allowed to play basketball he is allowed
to play twitter he's allowed to find
gifts and he found one of a honey badger
because
the honey badger aka tyron matthew going
to be signing with the kansas city
chiefs patrick mahomes is happy and
every chiefs fan should be happy about
the outcome chris a three-year 42
million dollar contract after a one-year
deal for seven million with the texans
the texans were trying to keep him as of
yesterday the texans were at nine and a
half million matthew decided to go to
the market he's cashing in with 14
million per year this is very good for
the chiefs they need help defensively
and they need to spend
while they have the money to spend that
has yet to go to patrick mahomes under
his next contract which is coming as
soon as next year yeah well i think it's
a great signing by the kansas city
chiefs first of all tyrone matthew
everything you hear about him total
professional great energy on a daily
basis i mean really loves football and
the other thing as far as football is
concerned is he kind of you know kills
two birds with one stone with what he
does on the defensive side of the ball
he can play the traditional safety role
when you need to do that he can play
nickel cover corner and be phenomenal at
that position as well so
it's the multiplicity he can bring to a
defense along with the attitude i think
is what you're paying for here and
kansas city of course had one of the
worst defenses in football last year so
i i like this signing a whole lot
yeah i really do like it and there are
chiefs fans out there who are smitten
with the idea that eric barry and tyron
matthew will be teamed up for the next
three years
my advice to them before you go get the
eric berry jersey you may already have
one if you don't i would wait because
there's a chance eric barry is not going
to be there next year as of march 15 a
7.25 million in base salary for eric
barry becomes fully guaranteed so there
could be a move made quickly and chris
with all the needs they have they've got
d ford under the franchise tag they're
trying to sign tyree kill they're going
to have to sign chris jones they have to
keep money aside for patrick holmes and
i know they've planned for that moment
but i i i'd be very surprised if they
keep both barry and tyron matthew unless
eric berry agrees to a dramatic
reduction of what he is due to make i
can't imagine the chiefs keeping both of
those guys on the roster well you know
they're ju they they got some tough
problems and it's a good problem to have
i mean yeah they got some superstar
talented players they don't have to play
mahomes yet so they got a little time to
buy there d ford is on the franchise
deal and i think that won't change i
don't think they're going to sign him to
a long-term deal he hasn't done enough
throughout his career to justify it yet
so they're going to make him prove it
for one more year that way only thing
i'll say with the eric berry
conversation mike is i you know with the
way his contract sets up if they let him
go i believe it's 14 million dollars
it's almost 15 million dollars in dead
money so i just can't imagine them being
able to swallow that pill going okay
yeah we're just going to leave 15 on the
floor 15 million on the floor there i
still think we get one more year of eric
berry in kansas city next year's a year
i think they get out of this so uh i
think we will be able to see honey
badger and barry together at least for
one season
there is a way to do this with a post
june 1 restructuring that would chop it
down to
let's see they can push eight million of
the cap charge into 2020. so they could
knock it down from 15 million to 7
million but it gets complicated because
you have to carry the guys entire cap
number until june 1 which could be a
problem but they can push eight million
to next year if they do it that way or
or they could just go to eric barry and
say look i mean we've gotten nothing out
of you the last two years and we know
injuries happened but we've gotten
nothing out of you the last two years we
can't justify paying you what we're
supposed to pay you and then the
question becomes will someone else pay
him more and could he be attracted to
join a team like the falcons in his his
native state of georgia where remember
that game a few years ago when he went
to the old georgia dome yeah he just
destroyed the falcons to the point where
i thought they would try to sign him as
a free agent that year well maybe they
do ask him you know for a pay cut
you know i think certainly i would be
concerned if i if eric barry did hit the
market with the guy that okay tears his
achilles tendon uh you know two years
ago at the start of the season
when they're when he's covering rob
gronkowski in that awesome season
opening game against the new england
patriots in the 2017 season but the 2018
season still having issues with that
same foot right he had heel issues right
so uh there is still certainly something
there in that area to where he couldn't
play till very late in the season and
and really could barely practice so i
think that would drive down his value it
is something to watch out for how they
play this whole eric berry angle out
here in the future
yeah and uh and again i don't want to be
a naysayer i don't want to be a a you
know a pessimist i'm just looking at the
cap i'm looking at who they need to sign
and you it's what other team has that
much tied up in the safety position and
i know tyron matthew does other things
but to have one guy making 13 million a
year and another guy making 14 million a
year that's a lot of money that's all
that's that's that's seahawks in their
prime type stuff and even they weren't
in that magnitude with both safeties in
eight figures
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports